It's fenben good for metastatic prostate cancer. Yes, it can be it can't be. It's certainly worth trying. There really isn't a downside of fenben.
So if you and back to that fenben question, you know, that was the where to go over that.
That was the protocol. Well, mostly you guys are already taking curcumin and a poppy and any of you are already taking burberry and CBD.
So just adding the fenben is all would be all the many of you would have to do to do that.
Can you run through the Joe Tippen's days of dosage for fenben and the other components.
No, again, it depends on the protocol. So the standard protocol for somebody who's not doesn't weigh a lot.
And their cancer isn't extremely aggressive at this time would be one packet a day for four days a week, along with curcumin, a poppy, burberry and CBD.
And it's typically three curcumin a day.
I think it's two a poppy a day and three burberry a day and one dropper for a CBD.
It's a liquid dropper the entourage and one packet, which is about, you know, about half a tablespoon in that packet.
You just put it in a smoothie and really has no taste.
If you weigh 200 pounds, you might do two packets a day, four days a week.
And you can play with that dose of fenben.
I have some people that are doing three packets a day, seven days a week.
Because their cancer is aggressive at this time and they're getting it really hard with this.
I've had lots of people turn their cancer around with that.
So it's something to worth investigating.